Clay Aiken issues an apology for a  defending Donald Trump against racist  accusations during his presidential  campaign it seems like the former  Celebrity Apprentice contestant has a  change of heart about the President of  the United States hours after Tuesday's  news conference where Trump blamed both  sides for white supremacist violence in  Charlottesville Virginia clay tweeted  remember all those times I defended at  real donald trump and the lead tea was  not actually racist well i am a [ __ ]  dumbass  hashtag i'm sorry i don't think he's a  fascist i don't think he's a racist I  think he's Democrat you'll recall the 38  year old pop star turned political  expert was very vocal about Trump amid  his run for office I will say this  Donald is always entertaining the  American Idol alum added quote I've  always thought he would be a dumpster  fire as a president and I was right  about that I just didn't think he was  racist  hashtag wrong  you  [Music]